Relief print making origins
started in hand-printing
meaning no press was required.
You are able as an artist
or a commercial printer
printing text able to transfer the image
by hand by use of a
baren. A baren is a small
object that allows you
to apply even pressure
larger than that of your hand.
In this case the block has been inked, and
a thin sheet of paper is
laid over top of the block.
With gentle pressure, apply to the block.
You can transfer the ink
to the sheet of paper.
A baren is typically used
on thin sheets of paper.
The heavier weight papers
that most artist use today
are too thick for hand to be
able to apply pressure all the
way through that sheet for an
even transfer of the image.
You can check the impression to
ensure you got a cool even pull.
Wood cuts use a flat piece
of wood in a case that we'll
demonstrate today. There
will be a cabinet grade
plywood which is extremely
dimensionally stable,
but still has a beautiful grain.
The grain of the wood and
wood cut is one reason that
artists utilize the material.
The grain provides a different
effect, in the black areas
of the print.
Contrast to something like linoleum cuts,
where the black ares are totally flat.
A wood cut, the grain will
affect just how heavily black the
black areas of the print can be printed.
The grain has a visual effect that can
often be used to an artist advantage.
When cutting on a wood block,
you use a different set of
tools much similar to
that of a wood carver or a
a cabinet maker.
These tools provide the
artist and the opportunity
to have a variety of marks, widths, and
depths from which to work with.
In relief print making a wood
cut block is prepared first by
toning the block with
an Indian ink wash or
a wash of a jet black film ink.
This provides a black
ground on the surface
from which to easily see to removed areas
of wood, to reveal the
drawing in a way that
allows the artist to
understand what is happening,
and where their drawing is going.
Once the block has been stained or toned,
the drawing can be
transferred through with
the aid of an iron oxide
or carbon paper transfer.
Once that paper transfer has been made,
the artist now has the
choice of deciding which
form of white line or
black line composition
to utilize.
White line is revealing
the image through thin
white lines in a black
field. That would be
cutting away those white
lines to leave the upper
area or black field to take ink.
The opposite way of
approaching the image area
is what we call black
line. Which is removing
the majority of the
information or wood to reveal
thin raised black lines
to accept the ink for
transfer to paper.
It is the balance of
white line and black line
that creates a sense of depth
or three-dimensionality.
Often an artist will have
a shift of white line
to black line to be able to reveal a more
representational or dimensional space.
Once the image has been
cut into the block,
the block is prepared for printing.
Ink is rolled over the
surface of the block,
placed on the press, and
past through transferring
ink to paper.
Linoleum block printing
or a liner cut is a
form of relief print making. It relies on
linoleum very much similar
to what would be in
someones home. A linoleum
tile, as being a very
flat consistent surface,
that you can gouge away
the non-image area. Linoleum block prints
provide a very specific
look, which would be
something that has a flat black area.
The type of linoleum block
print making that we do
today is very affordable and accessible.
The materials are easy to
use and easy for people
to begin understanding
the basic concept of print
making. Because of it's
affordability and ease
of use, it can be used
by a variety of different
people all across the
world. To have a very quick
transfer of an idea to
a block that can then be
replicated to print making.
Approaching a linoleum
block print has very
similar to that in
approaching of a wood cut.
The material in itself
can be toned just like
a wood block is toned, to
provide a black ground.
It makes it easier to see
what it is your cutting.
Linoleum in of itself, in a
material,does not necessarily
need that, because it's
fairly easy to see what
it is that your doing.
You can lay out your drawing ahead of time
with a marker, or also
a carving, or iron-oxide
transfer. In this case I
will approach the block
with the material blank and
develop the image as I go.
Also like a wood cut, if I remove
material, I can not be replace.
Whatever I cut away will be white.
Whatever remains will be black.
The tools we use for linoleum
cuts are very similar
to those of a wood cut.
The difference is the
type of metal that's
used. Linoleum is a much
softer material and
does not dull the tools
nearly as quickly as wood dulls the tools.
A high carving steel is
not necessarily required
for doing linoleum cut.
You can see the different
shapes here. A V gouge
and U tip. Very similar
to that of a wood cut.
These are the tools that
we use for linoleum cuts,
and the tools that we
have for wood cut are
very specific. Anything
that can remove material
is a tool that can be
used. An artist may use
a crowbar, screwdriver, a nail, and all of
these things that mark or
[mar 05:53] the surface
will provide image area.
Once you drawn a basic
image on the linoleum
block you can begin cutting. In this case
I've used some simple
text but remembering that
this will be printed in
reverse. Everything on
the block must be backwards.
So for printing a relief
block, that's a linoleum
cut, it's the same approach
as to printing a wood
cut. We want an even
application and anchor across
the entire block. In this
case, because the surface
of the linoleum will print a flat black.
We're insuring that we make a very even
application with no texture.